encuentra la probabilidad de escoger
aleatoriamente una canica amarilla de
una bolsa que contiene tres canicas
amarillas 2 rojas 2 verdes y una azul
déjenme escribo pe de probabilidad
lo que quiero es elegir elegir
una canica
vícam amarilla
amarilla esa es mi condición y el modo
en el que vamos a resolver esto es
calcular primero cuál es la cantidad de
posibles resultados y luego calcular de
esos posibles resultados cuáles
satisfacen la condición de ser amarillos
primero veamos quiénes son los posibles
resultados posibles
resultados el conjunto de posibles
resultados
pues tengo tres camisas amarillas tres
canicas amarillas aquí hay una y esta
otra que hay otra
tres canicas amarillas también tengo dos
camisas rojas
en una canica roja
otra canica roja
y también tengo dos canicas verdes
y mecánica verde y otra canica verde y
finalmente tengo una canica azul
esta mecánica azul así que estos son
todos los posibles resultados y a este
conjunto al conjunto de posibles
resultados hay gente que lo llama el
espacio muestral espacio
muestral o de muestreo también se usa de
muestreo
muy bien esto es un término bastante
rimbombante pero lo único que significa
es el conjunto de todos los posibles
resultados bien para calcular la
probabilidad de elegir una canica
amarilla
primero contamos cuál es el número total
de posibles resultados y aquí tengo 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 posibles resultados
así que este 8 es el número
de posibles
posibles resultados
--resultados
luego contamos de estos posibles
resultados cuantos satisfacen mi
condición de ser amarillos pues solo
tengo tres canicas amarillas tres
camisas amarillas así que este es el
número
d
--resultados
que satisfacen mis condiciones que
satisfacen mi condición
mis
y yo mes
esto es equivalente a preguntarme pues
cuántas canicas tengo pues tengo 8
canicas en la bolsa y de esas cuántas
son amarillas pues 3 canicas son
amarillas así que la probabilidad de
elegir una canica amarilla es igual a 3
entre 8